>> Sure, there's no doubt about it.
And there should be no discussion around that.
The question is when and how.
I think that we have some fundamental issues.
So if you look at the first 15, 20 years of
economic equalization, we
were focusing on areas which I guess are priorities
in terms of our
[INAUDIBLE] investment.
Institutional investment so on and so forth.
Where I think what is coming to fore in the
last 2 or 3 years and also
seems to me the theme for this year's conference
-- that's education
and health, which is getting importance in
other issues like women
empowerment and so on and so forth.
So I think either assume the center stage
and they should be important.
Everybody accepting that these challenges
continue to exist and I think
if we have a game plan with us, I think no
doubt about it that we will
realize our potential as being a super economic
power.